the man who's really led galvanized the
GOP efforts to rally behind judge
Cavanaugh is Lindsey Graham and one week
after his fiery call to arms and I loved
it the center is feeling more confident
than ever
after reading the FBI report on
Cavanaugh
senator Graham joins us now to talk
about that and what's next senator
thanks so much for being here tonight
what other games can we expect from the
Democrats before this thing goes to the
final vote think of the dumbest idea and
they'll do it whatever that is if they
ever write a book about overplaying your
hand in politics this is in the first
chapter the FBI reports supplemental
background check they interviewed nine
people they followed the direction of
the three senators who asked for more
FBI investigation it came back very good
for judge Cavanaugh and I would expect
these three senators will vote yes I
hope they will because that's what they
asked for the complaint from the left
there are a lot of them and we have a
few senators a few of your friends and
and others who who comment today let's
watch it's obviously a cover-up
the trunk White House working with the
Republican leadership in the Senate have
deliberately circumscribed this
investigation they're making a mockery
of the constitutional requirement that
the Senate provide its advise and
consent
that was boring if it that's an
investigation is a book investigation
the reality is that that is not a full
and thorough investigation it's not full
it's not thorough they didn't interview
Cavanaugh Ford or Deborah Ramirez's
second cousin twice removed to my good
friends this is advising consent this is
your view of the Senate's role is to
take a good man's life turn it upside
down betray dr. Ford's trust do
everything in the world to destroy him
to hold the seat open past the midterms
that's not advising consent that's
despicable it's going to blow up in her
face
hope it does because it was wrong he's
going to get on the court they have no
idea what the FBI supplemental
investigation was about they made up
their mind to vote no before anybody's
at hello so here's what the three
senators asked for that the Ford of the
people named by dr. Ford be interviewed
by the FBI just not the committee and
miss Ramirez be interviewed by the FBI
that was done plus four other five other
witnesses the results are in
senator Collins and Senator flake said
they thought it was thorough they
thought it was fair in these two people
who are my friends have no idea what
they're talking about and let me talk to
my friend Bob what y'all have done is
booked senator schumer talked about the
emotion that drove Christine Ford and
the country rallying behind her and it
seems like he's taken this into kind of
a mid-term pose let's watch dr. Ford
came forward in one America's hearts and
our Republican colleagues were upset
because that might derail their headlong
rush to put judge Cavanaugh on the
Supreme Court
your headlong rush you're rushing this
because you want to get it through as
fast as possible could be more of an
investigation but this was this was
emotionally based and you saw those
protesters today on Capitol Hill lots of
women they took over the heart office
building for I don't know how long but I
mean they promised that they're gonna
keep doing this senator Gramm they're
gonna keep hassling you guys in
elevators and cornering you in the halls
and the protest culture which I talked
about at the beginning of the show is
going to continue well it won't work
with me I think my colleagues feel
offended as to Senator Schumer I've
never been more disappointed in you and
your party you're the ones that knew
about dr. Ford's accusations in July she
requested to remain anonymous it was
somebody on your side who leaked it to
the press for a political purpose
somebody her own lawyers who were
advised to be appointed by senator
Feinstein the most politically active
person on the left apparently never told
dr. Ford that we had gone to California
to avoid her any embarrassment please
don't use and abuse this woman anymore
her accusations are have not been
corroborated time place location we
don't know any more now than we did
before the people she named says they
don't know what she's talking about so
really offends me that Senator Schumer
would continue to abuse dr. Ford they're
the ones who are playing politics I
voted for Sotomayor and Kagan never
thought twice about it but I'll tell you
right now this is the defining moment in
the 2018 election this is unfair
let's talk about repercussions for what
happened to either the filing of false
affidavits right that can be proved
possible obviously civil case defamation
but what it back to this leaking issue
which we talked about on the show
tonight before your appearance it seems
like someone's not telling the truth
here about what happened on the Senate
side sure do you believe what Dianne
Feinstein said when she said well I
didn't ask anyone then she turned around
and said well
oh no they tell me I did ask them and no
weed no one on my staff leaked this do
you believe that well I believe Dianne
Feinstein didn't leak it but I don't
know about her staff I do know this her
staff recommended to dr. Ford miss Katz
who hates Trump is a politically active
leftist lawyer and apparently dr. Ford
was not told by our legal team our
committee would have gone to California
do this in private I know somebody on
their side leaked an anonymous letter
without a postmark why not get the
emails and text here's what I'm gonna do
anybody who did this is going to pay a
price the people who exposed my name
senator Lee senator hatch that person's
going to pay a price my goal if I'm the
chairman of this committee is to make
sure it never happens again and the best
way to make sure it never happens again
is to punish those who did it what
lesson do you think the president should
take out of all of this I mean this was
a moment where the report II finally in
my mind got unified behind what this
president wants to do economy is on fire
great judges NAFTA renegotiated what's
next
the president should take the following
if you appoint a good person who gets
destroyed in a despicable manner and you
fight for him people will like you more
whether you're Trump Republican a Bush
Republican libertarian or vegetarian
Republican were all together now thanks
to this despicable attack on a good man
here's what I want the president
No do the right thing and fight for it
and you'll get rewarded Cavanaugh is
going to be on the bench and those who
tried to destroy him are going to be
looked at and they're going to pay a
price and I think this is going to help
us in the midterms I hate that this is
what it took to help Republicans but to
the other side you made the biggest
mistake of your life - they're three
Republicans you're all friends of mine
if you were yes before this debacle
please be yes now cause everything that
said about him
judge Kavanagh has fallen apart he's a
good man seven FBI investigations 156
people interviewed over 26 year period
all this stuff is garbage but do you but
you were a house impeachment manager
back in 1998 I remember it well and
Democrats are pledging some they take
the house they could very well move to
impeach Brett Kavanaugh I mean getting
him convicted the Senate would be very
difficult to do do you expect that to
happen if Republicans lose the house and
keep this saga going I think the
Democratic Party's been taken over by
irrationality hatred is their only
platform it's not about what they like
is who they hate and I can't believe in
America you have to prove yourself
innocent that you're guilty just by the
accusation that there's no requirement
to cooperate because you're Republican
if a democratic male nominee were
treated by the Republicans as Kavanagh
was treated by the Democrats every media
outlet in the country would be up in
arms Manchin real quick will he vote Yes
or now on Kavanagh if he listens to the
people of West Virginia he will Bret
deserves your vote Joe he's my friend
I've known him for a long time if you
listen to Schumer then the people of
West Virginia are gonna remember it
Lindsey Graham thank you so much for
being with us we really appreciate it
tonight